Rob handlery you went to play GTA 5 on
PC last week I want to know all about
all the editions are on the pc version
but first of all the new video editor
thing since you have this wonderful
diorama here yeah unfortunately they
didn't give us footage but this should
do fine at tell us about it so it's all
in Game four online or single player
we've got the idea is that you can
either hit record and start recording
okay they will be broken up into 30
second clips but it's still continuous
cool or you can backtrack 30 seconds and
record like an event or some got it so
like Xbox one it's always recording and
you can you can go back if you need to
yeah so then you take the footage and
you bring into rocks our editor yeah and
then you go to town and you would start
off by taking your clips and picking
your camera position I'm like
automatically to have to be in third
person if they're in first person you
can't do any different camera angles so
you if you're ever going to record
always be in third person so is it is it
recording the gameplay or is it
recording like the data of that 30
seconds and you can like swing around to
do whatever you want yeah exactly so
like you can do whatever you want in
kind of like a vicinity bubble so to
speak so you would have positions of
your camera you could do generic ones
like top-down view on the side or the
front and then you can get really
specific and you do what's called object
tracking right so if there was anything
in the bubble say a person another
player or even a bird or a plane or
anything like that I can either from my
view track that object or I could go to
that object and track any other object
in that bubble so that's anything within
like a specific amount of distance of
the player card yeah do you have big
that distance is it you get a feel for
it like was it two blocks how could you
it would be like a block okay I'd say a
block anyway so yeah you do it all these
different angles I can do hard cuts so I
could have a camera here and then the
camera is going to go to maybe other
side of the street or I can link them
with a kind of like a fluid dynamic
camera movement so the camera could pan
and end up here cool so outside of the
like cutting what I've is there in terms
of like visual effects k do like filter
is like color stuff yeah tons of stuff
there as well so you can do things like
add some camera shake you can either
slow down up to five percent
or you can speed up two hundred percent
all right add any kind of like filter
like you know anything like sepia to
black white any of those like Instagram
stuff like that on the yeah okay exactly
app on the phone or like the spectator
mode if you know like you can do like
all these different styled filters oh
yeah I wonder can you do the like the
weasel news exactly i get pretty sure
you can i flip them all pretty quick but
i'm very sure you can i would be
surprised yeah and then what about audio
because you know there's a lot of like
different noises going on at any GTA
playthrough you got like like the player
chatter you've got the in Game a car
audio and music and stuff like has all
that something yeah so there's basically
you're up front mixer so i can increase
sound effects beats music mixer board
basically and then what was pretty cool
is obviously you can use any of the
songs on the radio station although any
selection pick one pick one put in there
or which probably my favorite was if you
know of like the in-game score you can
lay that down and if something got maybe
like more action like explosion or maybe
we look more dramatic you can dip the
intensity of the score track to meet
whatever your video is about
so does that mean when you're doing this
you're either playing as Michael
Franklin Trevor or like your GTA online
character can you play as other people
yeah so there's director mode which
basically allows you to play as a wider
range of different people you see in GTA
cool so a weightlifter meathead dude
down on the beach they have like a
standard set as well as if you were to
play single player you kind of unlock
new ones so maybe it's like the alien in
a certain part where my fan out also
like stuff like animals as well done
yeah animals and as well as the ability
to immediately have five stars or change
the weather time of day there's a lot
more customizable aspects to like
creating your own rule oh that's cool
cinematic so it's not just like you're
you're selecting the highlights from
your like you playing the game they
actually are like sort of delving into
the machinima world and being like okay
you can set up the scene right and like
do whatever you want so then what about
sharing is this all gonna be on sitting
on rockstar social club can you stick it
on YouTube being export it yourself and
put it somewhere else yeah exactly so
you can do export all the clips need to
bring into like your own editing system
make your own video and upload it right
in Game two YouTube you can link your
YouTube account whoo yeah which is
perfect for so many people who just want
to get something out and about hmm so
attack next week and you've been playing
like God we were playing this forever
like 360 version history then we all
jump back on board and when xnk Matt we
all jump back on board when hice came
back and do you think you're gonna like
go back like just dominate on pc now
you're gonna concentrate on that stuff
having like play this it's it's close my
cuz i don't do i really want to transfer
my character again i'm up in the air but
i think there's enough there to like
coax GTA 5 files back yeah yeah it's
gonna be great and i am thoroughly
excited
you